el informe del senado llega a unas
conclusiones semejantes que aquel que
había sido solicitado por la primera
ministra elizabeth board hace algunas
semanas y es que el fiasco del 28 de
mayo se debió a una cadena de
disfuncionamientos y fallas y a la falta
de coordinación de las autoridades
competentes y también de los
organizadores del evento básicamente el
informe apunta a la prefectura de parís
pero también a las mentiras ya los
análisis poco precisos y parciales del
ministro del interior germán a situ
textual recordemos que el ministro tras
el partido dijo que la culpa de todo era
de los 30 mil a 40 mil hinchas del
liverpool que se habían presentado sin
entradas o con entradas falsas pero esto
luego se verificó no era cierto y en
junio del marán tuvo que pedir disculpas
a los hinchas del liverpool el informe
además entregó una serie de
recomendaciones ya que francia va a
organizar la copa mundial de rugby en el
2023 y los juegos olímpicos del 2024 y
la idea es no repetir los mismos errores
básicamente que se usen billetes que no
sean falsificables que las imágenes de
las cámaras de seguridad de estadios se
guarden por al menos un mes recordemos
que cuando se solicitó la información de
esas cámaras éstas habían sido tras una
semana como establecía hasta ese momento
la normativa y también que se establezca
un protocolo para el uso de los gases
lacrimógenes pues muchas de las personas
que llegaron al estadio aunque tenían
entradas no pudieron entrar y además se
vieron repelidas con gases lacrimógenos
los hinchas del liverpool una de las
principales asociaciones de hinchas dice
que está contento con este informe de
que el senado les de la razón en su
versión pero siguen esperando disculpas
oficiales del estado francés